mir geht es weiter mit dem
Jahressteuergesetz 2022 des
Jahressteuergesetz gibt es jedes Jahr in
die immer ein Bündel von
Steuerrechtsänderungen die hier noch
abschließend auf den Weg gebracht werden
erst an diesem Mittwoch haben sich die
Finanzpolitiker von SPD Grünen und FDP
auf letzte Änderung verständigt zu
diesem Gesetzespaket sondern ist jetzt
einfach mal gehört beispielsweise eine
erneute Erhöhung der Homeoffice
pauschale es gibt zusätzliche
Steuererleichterungen für Eigentümer
kleiner Solaranlagen
Sonderabschreibungen für den Wohnungsbau
und Bau und auch der Steuerfreibetrag
für Alleinerziehende soll herausgesetzt
werden wenn dieses Gesetz dann in Kraft
treten kann es gibt dann noch
Umsatzsteuer es geht auch um die
Umsatzsteuerpflicht der Kommunen also
jede Menge wir werden jede Menge auch
dazu hören und zunächst von Markus
Herbrand der ist finanzpolitischer
Sprecher der FDP-Fraktion
Jahressteuergesetz ein Gesamtkunstwerk
das in unserer ohnehin sehr komplexes
Steuerrecht noch mal in ganz vielen
Bereich eingreift es ist in diesem Jahr
das erste Jahressteuergesetz der
Ampelkoalition und siehe da es führt
nicht zu mehr Komplexität das kennen wir
aus der Vergangenheit sondern in vielen
Bereichen zu deutlichen Vereinfachungen
Entlastungen und auch Modernisierungen
bei der inhaltlichen Vorstellung des
Gesetzes will ich mich auf einige wenige
Punkte konzentrieren zunächst sei auch
festgestellt dass es vorhaben enthält
das nicht zu den lieblingsprojekten der
Liberalen Zellen auf die von uns nach
EU-Recht umzusetzen der EU Sonderabgabe
auffordert von Frau von der Leyen hätten
wir ebenso gerne verzichtet die auf die
verfassungsmäßig aber gebotene
Neubewertung von Immobilien im Rahmen
der Erbschaftsteuer auch wir halten es
nicht für fair wenn der Staat hier von
einer höheren Bewertung der Immobilien
zusätzlich profitiert allerdings ist die
Kritik der Union ein
Bundesfinanzminister Christian Lindner
sehr Schein heilig ihm also ein
Interesse zu unterstellen eine reine
ländersteuer zu erhöhen das ist schon
merkwürdig so leidensfähig in meinen
Augen ist auch Christian Lindner nicht
dass er sich freiwillig verprügeln lässt
für etwas von dem ausschließlich andere
profitieren die Union ist aufgefordert
hier über die Länder eine Änderung dazu
führen unsere Unterstützung haben sie
dabei
nun aber zu den mehr erfreulichen Dingen
dieses Gesetzes Kernpunkt des
Jahressteuergesetzes kernpunkt des
Jahressteuergesetzes sind weg wenn wir
die Energiewende ernst nehmen dann
müssen wir das riesige Potenzial der
dezentralen Stromversorgung aus
Photovoltaik nutzen und das gehen wir an
zwei Fronten an wir machen in deutlich
höheren Grenzen als bisher Erlöse und
Entnahmen aus diesen Anlagen bei der
ertragsteuerfrei und zwar rückwirkend
zum ersten ersten 2022 darüber hinaus
entbürokratisieren wir diesen Prozess
sehr deutlich im Hinblick auf die
Umsatzsteuer ganz lange bestehende
Hürden werden endlich abgebaut zukünftig
wird es so sein dass bestenfalls der
Bürger der eine solche Anlage
installiert mit dem Finanzamt deshalb
nichts mehr zu tun haben wird das ist
Entbürokratisierung
zweiter Punkt wir hatten uns auch
gemeinsam vorgenommen die Regelung zum
Homeoffice und zum Arbeitszimmer zu
vereinfachen das ist uns gelungen indem
wir die Anzahl möglicher
Fallkonstellationen in diesem Bereich
signifikant auf eigentlich nur noch zwei
Varianten reduziert haben zukünftig
werden die jahrespauschalen dann 1.260 €
betragen das entspricht einer
Tagespauschale von 6 € ist also auch
noch mal erhöht worden und zusätzlich
entfristet durch die Neuregelung
erhoffen wir uns sehr viel mehr
Rechtssicherheit auch und weniger Streit
zwischen steuerbürgerinnen und Bürger
und der Verwaltung der dritte Punkt auf
den ich zu sprechen kommen möchte der
Koalitionsvertrag sieht vor die
Klimawende voranzutreiben und neuen
Wohnraum zu schaffen und in beiden
Bereichen werden wir aktiv wir erhöhen
die lineare Abschreibung für
Investitionen in mit Gewalt auf drei
Prozent eine Forderung die wir Liberale
schon lange erheben darüber hinaus
nehmen wir die sonderfahrer für
Investitionen in mietwohnungs-
die Ende 2021 eigentlich ausgelaufen ist
wir bieten Bauherren eine neue
sonderarfe ab 23 an die aber als
zusätzliches Kriterium auch an die
Einhaltung des klimaschutzstandards eh
40 geknüpft ist so verbinden wir beides
miteinander Klimaschutz und bauen und
wir entlasten weiter endlich wird der
Sprache Freibetrag auf 1.000 Euro erhöht
eine längst überfällige Maßnahme und wir
gehen einen ersten Schritt auch im
Hinblick auf die Vermeidung der
Doppelbesteuerung bei Rentnern indem die
vollständige Absetzbarkeit der Beiträge
zur Rentenversicherung vorgezogen wird
weitere Schritte werden diesbezüglich
Folgen außerdem erhöhen wir nochmals den
Werbungskostenpauschbetrag sowie den
Entlastungsbetrag für Alleinerziehende
um 252 Euro auf jetzt
4.260 Euro alle vier Vorhaben stellen
weitere Entlastungen da
modernisieren vereinfachen entlasten
diesen Dreiklang der Koalition führen
wir auch mit diesem Gesetz herzlichen
Dank
Markus Herbrand ist der finanzpolitische
Sprecher der FDP-Fraktion und er nennt
das Jahressteuergesetz bzw das ist ja
noch keins den Entwurf dazu ein
Gesamtkunstwerk ich würde mal sagen es
ist ein Gemischtwarenladen viele Themen
viele Punkte in einem Gesetz dazu jetzt
Antje Tillmann die finanzpolitische
Sprecherin der Unionsfraktion
dieses
Gesetz Regelungen den wir zustimmen
können ich erwähne die Verbesserung beim
Wohnungsbau wir brauchen bezahlbaren
effizienten
energieeffizienten und auch mehr
Wohnraum und deshalb ist die sonderafa
richtig die sie auf den Weg bringen um
Wohnungs Neubau anzureizen wir finden
auch richtig dass die Gebäude aber auch
drei Prozent erhöht wird und dass sie im
Laufe des Verfahrens darauf verzichtet
haben die kürzeren Nutzungsdauer zu
streichen die nachweisbar gewesen wäre
sie hätten besser in dem Gesetz aber
auch das System des anschaffungsnahen
herstellungsaufwands geschliffen denn
auch das sind Hemmnisse für die
Sanierung
auch richtig finden wir dass die
Riester-Rente benutzt werden kann um
Gebäude energetisch zu sanieren bei der
Photovoltaik stehen wir bei Ihnen lange
Forderungen von uns dass
protopoltaikanlagen auf den Gebäuden
nicht zu zusätzlicher Bürokratie führen
darf es ist richtig den
Mehrwertsteuersatz auf neu zu reduzieren
und trotzdem den Vorsteuerabzug
zuzulassen unserem Antrag das ganze von
Juli auf Januar 2023 vorzuziehen sind
sie ebenfalls gefolgt herzlichen Dank
dafür auch ein paar Freibeträge die
erhöht werden also zum Beispiel der
Sparerfreibetrag auf 1000 €, der
Entlastungsbetrag für Alleinerziehende
ist gut ob die 30 Euro beim
Arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag den Braten fett
machen weiß ich jetzt nicht aber auch
dem würden wir zustimmen auch das
Vorziehen der
Rentenversicherungsbeiträge ist richtig
verfassungsrechtlich geboten aber leider
nur die Hälfte des Versprechens die
spätere Versteuerung der
rentenversicherungsrenten haben sie
nicht durchgesetzt in diesem Gesetz ich
bin sehr gespannt ob kommen wird leider
haben alle diese Vergünstigungen aber
einen Wermutstropfen sie machen diese
zusätzlichen Entlastung nämlich alle zu
Lasten der Schuldenbremse auf meine
Frage im Finanzausschuss wie sie die
kurzfristig eingeführten
Steuerentlastung der finanzieren wollten
da der Haushalt ja schon längst
verabschiedet ist haben Sie liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen der SPD amüsiert
zwischengerufen durch zusätzliche
globale Mehreinnahmen ich finde das gar
nicht witzig denn das zeigt ganz klar
wie sie mit dem Haushalt umgehen und
dass die Schuldenbremse ihn nichts mehr
wert ist ehrlich gesagt habe ich nicht
damit gerechnet dass es ausgerechnet ein
Finanzminister der FDP sein wird der die
Schuldenbremse schleift das ist sehr
sehr traurig
aber es gibt auch eine ganze Reihe von
Gründen die dazu führen dass dieses
Gesetz heute von uns abgelehnt wird ich
nenne die dezemberhilfe gut das
Bürgerinnen und Bürger hoffentlich bald
von den hohen Energiepreisen entlastet
werden wir haben zugestimmt dass sie den
Dezember energieabschlag erstattet
bekommen und es ist irgendwie auch
nachvollziehbar dass sie Gerechtigkeit
herstellen wollen und deshalb eine
Steuerpflicht wollen niemand von ihnen
einschließlich des BMF konnte mir aber
im Ausschuss erklären wie diese
Steuerpflicht umgesetzt werden sollen
die Pflichten werden auch erst in dem
Gesetz nächstes Jahr verabschiedet und
da steht drin Stadtwerke und alle
Vermieterinnen und Vermieter sollen
Namen und Adressen des Kunden an einen
noch zu bestimmende Stelle schicken
dann die Steuer-ID zusteuern und
irgendjemand soll dann bei 20 Millionen
Gasverträgen prüfen ob derjenige
vielleicht auch noch
Solidaritätszuschlag sind
eine Bürokratie wo jetzt schon die
Stadtwerke sagen es ist nicht leistbar
ich kann mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen
anders gehen soll der ehrliche der
selber versteuert und selber angibt wird
der Dumme sein in der Anhörungen ist
gesagt worden die Stadtwerke werden
schon den richtigen treffen selbst die
Steuergewerkschaft sagt bei der
dezemberhilfe wird es zu
Ungerechtigkeiten kommen da ist aus
meiner Sicht nicht Besteuerung schon
deutlich gerechter als das was sie hier
Vorhaben noch krasser zeigt beim
energie-soli beim Solidar Beitrag die
sie mit Rechtsstaatlichkeit umgehen über
Monate haben wir alle vermieden diesen
Solidarbeitrag als abschöpfungssteuer zu
bezeichnen weil wir dann in der EU ein
Einstimmigkeitsprinzip gehabt hätten
Steuermaßnahmen müssen auf EU-Ebene
einstimmig beschlossen werden wir
wussten dass wir diese Mehrheiten nicht
kriegen jetzt ist in dem Gesetzentwurf
auf einer
ermächtigungsvorschriftartikel 122
verwiesen die auf diese Einstimmigkeit
verzichtet aber was machen Sie sie
schreiben ins Steuergesetz rein dieser
Solidar Beitrag ist eine Steuer alle
Sachverständigen auch ihre haben in der
Anhörung des problematisiert
sehen in eine große rechtssicher
Unsicherheit wir wissen dass dieses
Gesetz beklagt werden wird wir werden 1
bis 3 Milliarden Euro tatsächlich
vermutlich wieder zurückzahlen müssen
aber vielleicht ist das auch der neue
Trick zur Umgehung der Schuldenbremse
dass wir mit Einnahmen kalkulieren Sie
auch ausgeben obwohl wir genau wissen
dass wir zurückzahlen müssen dieses
Risiko werden wir nicht verantworten das
müssen sie tun auch aus diesem Grund
werden wir dieses Gesetz ablehnen
für die SPD-Fraktion hat pasernavi das
Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen satte 18
Verhandlungsrunden und unzählige
Gespräche liegen im Rahmen dieses
Gesetzgebungsverfahrens hinter uns die
intensive Arbeit von uns als
ampelfraktionen an diesem
Jahressteuergesetz hat sich gelohnt wir
haben dieses gute Gesetz noch einmal
deutlich verbessern können
wer sind nun die Gewinnerinnen und
Gewinner unserer Verhandlung gewonnen
haben Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
die entlastet werden gewonnen hat der
Wohnungsbau den wir soziald und
klimagerecht fördern gewonnen hat die
Energiewende durch wenige Bürokratie bei
Photovoltaikanlagen und gewonnen hat die
Solidarität bei der Krisenbewältigung
durch die Abschaffung von zufallsgewinn
dafür machen wir gerne Politik meine
Damen und Herren
wir haben insgesamt eine Menge für die
Beschäftigten erreicht Vorziehen des
100%igen Steuerabzugs für
altersvorsorgeaufwendung auf 2023
Anhebung Ausbildungsfreibetrag Anhebung
Sparer Pauschbetrag genauso wie im
Koalitionsvertrag festgelegt wir heben
neu den Arbeitnehmer Pauschbetrag
zusätzlich an und auch die Homeoffice
pauschale auf maximal
1260 Euro und damit 260 € höher als im
Regierungsentwurf und auch das ist neu
im Regierungs gegenüber dem
Regierungsentwurf das hat mein Kollege
Herr Brand ausgeführt wir
vereinheitlichen für unzählige
beschäftigte die Homeoffice pauschale
und das sogenannte häusliche
Arbeitszimmer ein Paragraph der mir im
Studium auch immer wieder begegnet ist
zu einer einheitlichen Tagespauschale
somit muss in ganz vielen Fällen keinen
abgeschlossenes Arbeitszimmer mehr
vorgehalten werden das vereinfacht den
Zugang für Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer und vereinfachte
Steuerrecht wir reden nicht nur über
sinnvolle Verantwortung des Steuerrecht
wie setzen Sie jetzt Ampel auch endlich
in die Tat um Liebe
das haben wir mit ähnlichen bekommen von
der Union wir setzen mit diesem Gesetz
den eu-energie krisenbeitrag um darüber
haben wir als SPD schon vor Monaten
gesprochen endlich können wir hier einen
Knopf dran machen wir orientieren uns
eng an den EU-Vorgaben und ich finde es
aber ausdrücklich gut dass wir den
Besteuerungszeitraum aus 2022 und 2023
festgelegt haben und auch Vorkehrungen
treffen damit Unternehmen zum Beispiel
nicht über das Instrument von Umwandlung
unter den Radar des Gesetzes kommen
endlich werden zufallsgewinne von Kohle
Öl und Energieunternehmen für eine
solidarische Krisenbewältigung
herangezogen das ist ein ganz wichtiger
Beitrag für mehr Steuergerechtigkeit
meine Damen und Herren
und schließlich haben wir genauer
hingeschaut bei der Besteuerung der
Nutzung und Überlastung von Rechten an
einem inländischen Register das sind zum
Beispiel Lizenzgeschäfte die in einer
digitalen Wirtschaftswelt immer
wichtiger werden wir wollen dass der
besteuerungsanspruch für die sogenannten
innerkonzernfälle nicht wie
Regierungsentwurf vorgesehen in vielen
Fällen entfällt sondern neben der schmal
geschnittenen
eu-steuer-oasen Liste eine eigene
nationale Liste für nicht dba-staaten in
einem weiteren Gesetzgebungsverfahren
erarbeitet wird wir haben nichts gegen
einfache Handhabung in der Praxis aber
wir wollen potenziellen Steuergestaltung
ein Riegel vorschieben so weit reicht
jedenfalls unsere sozialdemokratische
forschungskraft meine Damen und Herren
alles in allem verabschieden wir heute
ein gutes
Gesetzespaket für das die ampelfraktion
ein wesentlichen Beitrag geleistet haben
ein herzlicher Dank geht mein
mitberichterstattern Michael strudy Tim
küstentorf und Bernhard dahltrup den
Kollegen Kollegen von der ampelfraktion
unseren tollen fraktionsbüros und
Referentin Referenten dem Sekretariat
des Finanzausschusses und natürlich den
Bundesministerium Finanzen für die gute
Zusammenarbeit vielen Dank
aus der SPD-Fraktion König sein aus der
afd-fraktion die AFD legt sie in dieser
Debatte auch zwei Anträge vor zum einen
fordert sie eine Tarif Ermäßigung bei
Einkünften aus Land und Forstwirtschaft
die eigentlich Ende des Jahres auslaufen
sollte bis 2031 weiterhin zur Anwendung
kommen zu lassen und in einem anderen
Antrag das viele Betreiber weiß sie
daraufhin dass viele Betreiber von
kleinen Fotovoltaikanlagen und
Blockheizkraftwerken
ja in steuerlichen Behandlung
benachteiligt sein da verlangt die AFD
Änderungen
Maßnahmen die über Nacht durchgearbeitet
werden mussten diesmal waren es 39
Änderungsanträge von denen der letzte
erst zwei Minuten vor der
Ausschusssitzung bei uns ankam und in
der Sitzung sollte man dann Sach- und
fachkundig darüber diskutieren und
entscheiden ein absolutes Ding der
Unmöglichkeit und so geht man mit
Abgeordneten nicht um
im vorliegenden Jahre Steuergesetz gibt
es viele gute Dinge ein Skandal und ein
paar schlechte Bestimmungen gut sind die
neuen Bestimmungen zum
grundrentenzuschlag zum häuslichen
Arbeitszimmer zur homeoffice-pauschale
zur
gebäude-verfahren zu den Verlusten bei
Kapitaleinkünften sowie die Anhebung
vieler Freibeträge wie an die
Ausbildungsfreibetrag und der
sparer-wi hat sich ja gerade gesagt auch
die ertrags- und Umsatzsteuerbefreiung
für die Photovoltaik ist gut aber damit
ist leider leider nein ja weil wir eben
nicht darüber diskutieren konnten
ich finde es trotzdem gut aber damit ist
leider noch nicht das Problem bei den
bestehenden Anlagen gelöst
wir glauben nicht an die
menschengemachten Klimawandel wir
fordern in den unseren neuen in unserem
beigestellten Antrag einen
Vertrauensschutz bei der Besteuerung
dieser Anlagen denn es ist nämlich
paradox bei der Richtung der Altanlagen
war eine Steuerpflicht auferlegt aber
die steuerlichen Verluste ab 2018 kam
wird die werden nicht anerkannt ich
komme aus Niedersachsen und für unsere
Landwirte ist es ein bitteres Zeichen
dass auf die Bundesregierung kein
Verlass ist die Fortsetzung der
tarifglättung nach § 32c
Einkommensteuergesetz hätte als
Einkommensteuer förderliches Zeichen der
langfristigen Solidarität zwingen in
dieses Gesetz gehört das bedeutet so wie
es jetzt ist bedeutet es nämlich
nettoeinkommensverluste für die
Landwirtschaft die Ampel nimmt den
Landwirten dieses erst kürzlich
eingeführte Instrument wieder aus der
Hand frecherweise ohne eine Ersatzlösung
anzubieten
schlecht sind zum Beispiel die faktische
Erhöhung der Erbschaftssteuer bei
Immobilien und auch den direkten
Zahlungsweg sehen wir skeptisch obwohl
jetzt eine freiwillige Lösung angewendet
wird kommen wir zum Skandal
die Ampel führt im omnibusverfahren eine
neue Steuer ein und nennt es in EU
energiekrisenbeitrag im Grunde ist das
die umstrittene übergewinnsteuer in
einer Tarnkappe und hierzu zitiere ich
den ehemaligen Vorsitzenden des ersten
Senates des Bundesfinanzhofes Prof dr
Gosch in seiner Stellungnahme zur
öffentlichen Anhörung Artikel 122 Absatz
1 AEUV bietet weder aus materiellen noch
aus formalen Gründen eine ausreichende
Ermächtigungsgrundlage für einen
befristeten solidaritäts-
die geplante Maßnahme unterläuft die
verfahrensanforderungen und kollidiert
mit den vorrangigem Namen Normen des AUV
es gibt offene viel diskutierte und auf
der Hand liegende Verfassungsfragen
Artikel 3 Absatz 1 und Artikel 14
Grundgesetz Zitat Ende
kann man so machen auch die an beiden
anderen Sachverständigen haben genau
diese Fragen pro problematisiert auch
der wissenschaftliche Beirat beim
Bundesministerium der Finanzen rieb noch
in seinem Gutachten vom Juli 2022
dringend davon ab eine kurzfristig
politisch opportun erscheinen aber
langfristig schädliche übergewinnsteuer
einzuführen das ganze das ganze war uns
so wichtig dass wir über diesen Punkt
eine getrennte Abstimmung verlangen wir
lehnen die übergewinnsteuer in der
Tarnkappe des EU Energie-
würden wir zustimmen wenn eben halt
diese Bestimmung mit dem mit der
eu-energiekrise rauskommt ansonsten
werden wir uns enthalten vielen Dank für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
König war das aus der afd-fraktion und
die Eingang schon gesagt hier auch zwei
Anträge vorliegt in dieser zu dieser
Debatte Katharina Weg ist sie nächste
Rednerin finanzpolitische Sprecherin der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Kolleginnen verlegen liebe Bürgerinnen
und Bürger ich habe gerade einen ganz
tolle neuen Begriff für Sammelsurium
Potpourri Gesetze die viele Dinge reden
ihr lernt nämlich Gesamtkunstwerk vielen
Dank lieber Markus herbrandt dazu denn
dieses Jahressteuergesetz vereint
unfassbar viele Regeln unterschiedlicher
Natur aber man kann dieses
Gesamtkunstwerk auf zwei Dinge
zusammenfassen echte Innovationskraft
und zusätzliche Entlastungen die diesem
Land wirklich gut kommt tun wir machen
echte Innovationskraft beispielsweise
und wir haben 39 Dinge noch mal
nachgeschärft hier im Parlament mit all
den Menschen die hier dran beteiligt
waren tolle Entwürfe aus dem BMF aber
eben auch hier im Parlament PV sogar
rückwirkend für dieses Jahr wenn man
eine Solaranlage sich installiert auch
sein darf kann man das rückwirkten
dieses Jahr schon nur mit 0% besteuern
hat viel weniger Bürokratie und das ist
langfristig einfach toll für den
Standort Deutschland für bessere
erneuerbare Energien und dezentrale
Energieversorgung bei den Entlastungen
haben wir nicht nur die
rentenbeitragszahlerinnen und in was
sowieso auch vereinbart waren
vorangetrieben sondern wir heben zwar
klein aber immerhin auch den
Arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag noch mal an und
was ganz besonders wichtig ist ich
glaube auch gerade nach der corona-krise
die Familien und Menschen mit Kindern so
stark betroffen haben den
Alleinerziehenden Entlastungsbetrag
heben wir auch noch mal an um 252 Euro
. wir persönlich als für
immobilienbesteuerung zuständige auch
ist mir besonders wichtig dass wir
endlich Öko und sozial verbinden in
diesem Gesetz wir heben zwar auch die
Neubau Prämie an bzw erneuerbar AfA an
aber eben noch zusätzlich und Top mit
5%, eine sonderfahrer die wir hier im
Parlament erarbeitet haben die nicht nur
eine soziale einen Reiz hat sondern auch
ein ökologischen und so hat man dann im
Endeffekt auch im unteren Preissegment
endlich Wohnungen die so gut gedämmt
sind das ist nicht so teuer ist dort zu
halten das geht super zusammen und ich
freue mich dass wir diese
Innovationskraft endlich mal nutzen und
aufzeigen dass das geht vielen Dank an
alle Kollegen und beim
energiekrisenbeitrag es ist historisch
vor einem halben Jahr hätte niemand
gedacht dass wir als Ampere hier die
Mineralölkonzerne beteiligen an der
Bewältigung dieser Krise das ist schon
historisch danke allen die da auch über
ihren Schatten gesprungen sind wir
werden hier die Bemessungsgrundlage und
Steuersatz so übernehmen wie es von der
EU vorgeschlagen ist wir haben im
Parlament die Paragraphen aber auch
genau gelesen und noch eine
Umgehungstatbestand ausgeräumt bei den
Umwandlungen hier waren wir sehr gut
unterwegs gemeinsam und was ich schon
sagen möchte ist wir senden ein tolles
marktsignal dass wir nicht nur ein Jahr
sondern zwei Jahre nehmen denn bis das
Kartellrecht endlich nachgeschärft ist
es sehr gut dass dieses Instrument wie
so eine Art Brücke wirkt damit eben der
Markt Macht der Konzerne die die Preise
so gut setzen können hier ein Riegel
vorgeschoben wird vielen Dank dafür und
zum Schluss möchte ich mich explizit bei
allen Beteiligten aber eben vor allem
auch bei unseren Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeitern in den Büros in den
Fraktion im BMS bedanken denn da waren
sehr viele Nachtschichten mit involviert
und das ist wirklich nicht normal aber
toll weil so vielen tollen Dingen die
wir fürs Land vorbei bringen und zum
Schluss Frau Kolleginnen dass er im
Bundesrat sehr schnell damit fertig
werden dass diese Entlastung und
Innovationsanreize für das Deutschland
indem wir gerne leben wollen
vielen Dank
sanfte Ermahnung von
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin katrin
Göring-Eckardt an Katharina Beck die
finanzpolitische Sprecherin der
Grünen Fraktion nächster Redner ist
Christian Görke finanzpolitischer
Sprecher der Linksfraktion und
ehemaliger Finanzminister in Brandenburg
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das Jahr Steuergesetz ist ja
immer eine ganze ein ganzer Fuß von
verschiedensten Maßnahmen aus unserer
sich mit viel Licht aber ordentlichen
Schatten sie Planer ist das Novum im
Umsatzsteuerrecht 0% Umsatzsteuer auf
die Lieferung von Photovoltaikanlagen
gut so das unterstützen wir als LINKE
ausdrücklich dort stellt sich die Frage
warum nur dort die Umsatzsteuer befreien
Landwirtschaftsminister
wiederholt Obst und Gemüse von der
Umsatzsteuer befreien zu wollen dass
sagte er sozialwirtschaftlich und
klimapolitische sinnvoll richtig sagen
wir dort sind wir im Gegensatz zur
Öko-Partei und vorweg da wollen wir
natürlich Öko und sozial verbinden dafür
dass wir alle Gründen Nahrungsmittel von
der Steuer befreien nicht nur Obst und
Gemüse sondern auch Butter Brot Milch
und Eier und meine Damen und Herren
Grundnahrungsmittel die auch in der
Krise jeder braucht weder braucht müssen
auch bezahlbar sein und soll müssen
nicht noch mit einer Steuer verteuert
werden wo dann auch noch der dieser
Finanzminister ran verdient dass dazu
meine Damen und Herren manchmal denke
ich in diesem Land gilt das Motto nur
wer hat dem wird gegeben weit gefehlt es
wurde noch besser wer in der Krise aber
Milliarden verdient dem wird auch nicht
mehr genommen Thema übergewinnsteuer
meine Damen und Herren und damit komme
ich zu Ihnen meine Damen und Herren von
der Ampel man musste sie ja regelrecht
zwingen zumindestens die EU dass sie die
überschäumende Gewinne der
Energiekonzerne mit der Suppenkelle
abschöpfen
und jetzt kommt raus sie nehmen nicht
mal eine dessert-löffel statt der
Suppenkelle denn sie sind offensichtlich
eingeknickt vor den energielobbyisten
seit Januar klingelt die Kassen der
Energiekonzerne und sie lassen sagen und
schreibe Milliarden Krisen Gewinne der
Stromproduzenten in 2022 nahezu
unbesteuert durchlaufen 11 Monate
kriegsgewinne Freihaus während die
Menschen unter anderem in meinem
Bundesland Brandenburg Angst haben vor
der nächsten Abrechnung wie ungerecht
ist das denn meine Damen und Herren und
nicht anders ist es beim Öl und Gas sie
folgen auch hier nur den minimal
Kompromiss der EU und öffnen zudem auch
noch mit dem Gesetz den Konzern Tür und
Tor um ihre Gewinne dann auch noch klein
zu rechnen die Deutschen haben in diesem
Jahr 2022 ungefähr 60 bis 80 Milliarden
Euro mehr für Gas für Öl und Benzin
bezahlt und diese 60 bis Milliarden sind
überwiegend als Gewinne bei den
mineralökonzernen angekommen und sie
wollen allen Ernstes bei Öl und Gas nur
maximal ein bis drei Milliarden davon
abschöpfen und meine Damen und Herren
das ist nicht nur skandalös und
angesichts der Äußerungen von Bündnis 90
Grünen und auch der SPD ist das
eigentlich beschämend vielen Dank
Christian Görke sieht die Möglichkeiten
bei der übergewinnsteuer noch nicht
hinreichend ausgeschöpft auch das ein
Teil des Jahressteuergesetzes 2022
nichts Bernhard da drauf aus der
SPD-Fraktion und da ist der
kommunalpolitischer Sprecher
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wenn über 70
Änderungsanträge von der Ampel Bundesrat
wenn sie sozusagen in über 18 Gesprächen
der Koalitionäre mit den Ministerium
diskutiert werden dann zeigt dass sie
Komplexität des Jahressteuergesetzes
aber auch das nehme ich schon für uns in
Anspruch die Ernsthaftigkeit mit der wir
den Anliegen Rechnung tragen wollen
deswegen herzlichen Dank an alle
Beteiligten differenziert die das eben
schon mal vorgetragen ist dem schließe
ich mich ausdrücklich an ich kann nicht
über alle Punkte jetzt reden wegen
meiner begrenzten Zeit deswegen treffe
ich einfach nur eine Feststellung was
die Frage zum Beispiel
des EU krisenbeitrags und andere Dinge
angeht die Union und die Ampel haben in
diesen Fragen eine unterschiedliche
Vorstellung von Gerechtigkeit und wir
haben einen Maß nein wir haben einen
Maßstab von Gerechtigkeit der die
Leistungsfähigkeit der Betroffenen
sozusagen einbezieht die wollen Sie auf
dieser Art und Weise nicht und das ist
ein Unterschied ich stell den hier fest
und ich werde darüber auch öffentlich
gerne reden ich bin aber das will ich
noch mal sagen ja man muss es ja auch
mal öffentlich sagen ich will aber mal
sagen ich bin mit den Ergebnissen dieser
Beratungen zum Jahressteuergesetz
wirklich zufrieden und will das am
Beispiel der Wohnungspolitik vielleicht
mal sagen die Wohnungspolitik gehört ja
zu den Schwerpunkten dieser Regierung
und ja der Motor ist ein bisschen ins
Stopp geraten und stellt sich die Frage
kann eigentlich über das Steuerrecht
kann eigentlich über das Jahre
Steuergesetz ein neuer Impuls im
Zeitalter von Klimawandel sozusagen
ausgelöst werden denn die Regierung
macht ja in diesem Bereich im bereits
eine Menge es gibt milliardenprogramme
für Sanierung von Wohngebäuden es gibt
große große Beträge wenn es um die Frage
geht des bezahlbaren Wohnungs auch für
die Eigentumsförderung und trotzdem wie
hilft das Jahressteuergesetz in dieser
Situation Herr Kollege möchten Sie eine
Zwischenfrage aus der AFD
erstens wir erhöhen wieder schon mehrere
gesagt hat gesagt haben im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart die lineare
Abschreibung von Wohngebäuden auf
aktuell zwei auf drei Prozent zum ersten
ersten 2023 seit Jahren gefordert wir
setzen das jetzt in dieser Ampel um
zweitens
gleichzeitig bleibt die Möglichkeit
erhalten eine Schrottimmobilie durch den
Nachweis einer tatsächlich kürzeren
Nutzungsdauer schneller abzuschreiben
wir folgen an begründeten Wunsch der
Wohnungswirtschaft auch des Bundesrates
richtig so drittens um einen
klimapolitischen zusätzlichen Impuls zu
geben legen wir eine sonderfahrer mit
deutlichen Akzent zu Stärkung des
bezahlbaren und klimagerechten
mietwohnungs- innerhalb von fünf Jahren
können innerhalb von vier Jahren können
5% der Herstellungskosten für neu
geschaffene Mietwohnungsbau steuerlich
abgesetzt werden wenn die Anforderungen
gehen nicht vergessen dabei erfüllt sind
und nicht den den Bau von Luxuswohnungen
zu steuerlich zu begünstigen setzen wir
eine Obergrenze 4.800 und ein aphasat
2500 Euro ein das ist glaube ich sehr
vernünftig und ich bin sehr dankbar
allen Beteiligten dass wir das gemeinsam
hinbekommen und wir verknüpfen ich kann
da anknüpfen diese Energieziele auch mit
sozialen und demografischen Komponente
wir alle kennen den Wohnriester wer ist
mit den Mitteln kann man eine Wohnung
ein Haus altersgerecht umbauen damit
Menschen länger gute in ihrer Wohnung
leben können nicht möglich war es bisher
den Riester auch für energetische
Sanierung am selbst genutzten
Wohngebäude einzusetzen künftig geht das
ich finde das ist vernünftig zu mal
dahinter ein Milliarden Volumen dass der
Wohnungswirtschaft zu Gute kommen kann
dahinter steht mein Kollege den
Düsseldorf wir gleich noch das Thema
vertiefen was ihr schon mehrfach
angesprochen worden ist das Thema
Photovoltaik wie wir es fördern wollen
auf dem Weg vom energieverbrauchenden
zum Energie schaffenden Haus das ist ein
grundlegendes unterschiedliches
Verständnis dass wir auch haben und ich
bin sehr froh darüber dass wir diese
rückwirkende Steuerbefreiung für
Kleinanlagen und so weiter hinbekommen
haben tolle Sache Einsatz will ich an
die Bauwirtschaft richten wenn das noch
gestattet ist ganz kurz wer 300.000
Wohnungen baut der kommt zu einem guten
Erfolg wenn das in stocken Geräten
müssen wir uns aber auch die Frage
stellen was eigentlich an
Produktivitätsfortschritten in der
Bauwirtschaft möglich ist und ob diese
Potenziale schon eigentlich ausgeschöpft
sind das sind sie meines Erachtens nicht
und das ist eine Frage die Bauwirtschaft
auch selber lösen muss Zeit zu Ende
deswegen
höre ich es auch auf zu reden und glaube
dass wir was Gutes hinbekommen haben
herzlichen Dank
bernhard dahldruck hat er noch ein paar
Sekunden gefeilt am Ende seiner Räder zu
Redezeit die eigentlich schon abgelaufen
war jetzt kommt Sebastian Brehm
nein jetzt kommt die kurze Intervention
von Kai Gottschalk der ist
finanzpolitischer Sprecher der
afd-fraktion demokratisch Verhalten und
keine Zwischenfragen meiner Fraktion
zulassen aber Herr Kollege Daldrup habe
ich sie also jetzt richtig verstanden
dass aufgrund der Äußerungen der
Kollegin Tillmann die sehr gut
ausgeführt hat das
rückforderungsrisiken Bestehen bezüglich
ihrer
Ermächtigungsgrundlage Herr König hat es
mein Kollege Johann König eben
ausgeführt das ist also der Linken
Doktrin und Ideologie hier im Hause
entspricht wenn man es also nur mit dem
Begriff und Etikett Gerechtigkeit und
zwar nach ihrer Definition bezeichnen
kann dass man dann rechts und
Verfassungsbruch begehen kann ähnlich
wie wir es ja auf den Straßen hier in
Deutschland gerade erleben das heißt
also sie haben schon verstanden implizit
dass sie über den Paragraph 122 EUV die
falsche Ermächtigungsgrundlage genommen
haben das heißt der Energie
Notverordnung und daraus eine
übergewinnsteuer Frau Tillmann hat es
ausgeführt ableiten und sie sind sich
also dessen beklagt das haben sie eben
ausgeführt und gehen offen in einen
Verfassungsbruch dann würde ich
vielleicht ein Haldenwang mal den Tipp
geben vielleicht mal genauer bei der SPD
hinzuschauen als laufend bei uns oder
vielleicht auch bei den straßenklebern
und nicht immer bei den Menschen die
gegen ihre corona-politik demonstrieren
wenn sie mir das erläutern
möchten Sie antworten
[Applaus]
ich kann ganz kurz antworten der wird
schon sie sind mit der Frage angefangen
ob sie richtig
ja bin ich ja die Mikros sind mit der
Bemerkung angefangen ob sie mich richtig
verstanden haben und haben dann
hinterher sozusagen die Kurve gekriegt
ob ich Sie richtig verstanden habe ich
weiß jetzt nicht was sie verstanden
haben und was sie nicht verstanden haben
das können wir bei Gelegenheit noch mal
klarstellen ich weiß sehr wohl dass die
Fähigkeit etwas zu verstehen bei ihnen
nicht von der Beratungszeit abhängt
danke schön
das Wortteil Sebastian in Bremen für die
CDU-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
jahressteuergesetze sind ja immer
komplexe Angelegenheiten und dann
diesjährigen Jahressteuergesetz alleine
hatte der Referentenentwurf 142 Seiten
70 Anträge Kollege darüber zu erwähnt 16
verschiedene Gesetze und Verordnungen
werden umfasst und letztlich handelt
sich eben doch um ein Sammelsurium wie
in jedem Steuergesetz in jedem
Jahressteuergesetz uns eines muss man
der Ampel lassen
hier ist es in diesem Jahr gelungen
einen gewissen roten oder
rot-gelb-grünen Faden in all diese
Änderungen zu bringen
klatschen sie nicht zu früh der rote
Faden ist fast alle Änderungen sind in
irgendeiner Weise unstimmig liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen erstens
praxisuntauglichkeit der Vorschriften
zweitens
mutmaßliche Verfassungswidrigkeit von
Vorschriften und drittens offener
Wahlbetrug liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ich will das nicht nur behaupten
sondern ich will jede unstimmigkeitsart
auch mit einem konkreten Beispiel
versehen angefangen mit der fehlenden
Praxis Untauglichkeit
die von der Ampel vorgenommene
Besteuerung der energiepreispauschale
für Rentnerinnen und Rentner sowie die
Besteuerung des gasabschlags sind
handwerklich so schlecht dass die
Bundesländer sogar drohen muss den
Vermittlungsausschuss zu gehen oder
drohen werden weil sie fürchten dass es
eine überbortende Bürokratie ist und
gerade dass das Veranlagungsverfahren in
den Finanzämtern stocken wird also was
sie hier machen Herr Maria sie haben
gesagt sie haben irgendwie vereinfacht
was sie hier machen ist pures
verwaltungsbürokratie Chaos das ist das
was man hier unter subsumieren muss
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
zweitens mit der Verfassungswidrigkeit
der fachlich nicht zuständige
Wirtschaftsminister hat mit seinen
Beratern auf der falschen
Rechtsgrundlage eine diskriminierende
übergewinnsteuer geschaffen die in
einigen Fällen sogar zur erheblichen
Besteuerung führen wird
wenn man schon Umverteilung vornehmen
will dann muss man es wenigstens auch
richtig machen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und da muss man es auch
fachlich richtig machen in der
öffentlichen Anhörung am Montag haben
die Sachverständigen keinen Zweifel
daran gelassen dass das was die Ampel
hier plant
unionrechtswidrig und verfassungswidrig
ist wir werden sehen wie das ausgeht und
drittens liebe Kollegen
der offene Wahlbetrug die FDP und ich
kann das nur noch mal aus der Debatte
gestern wiederholen die FDP hat gesagt
und im Wahlkampf versprochen es wird
keine Steuererhöhungen geben
steuererhöhungen sind Sabotage am
Aufschwung und erst am 28 November des
muss man einfach auch nochmal heute hier
erwähnen hat der Bundesfinanzminister
Christian Lindner beim deutschen
zentralverall beim Zentralverband des
Deutschen Handwerks gesagt wir sind in
der Vorweihnachtszeit fürchtet euch
nicht man muss das noch mal wiederholen
weil es ist erst vor 4 Tagen gesagt
worden und sie lachen aber die Menschen
da draußen Lachen nicht weil sie greifen
mit ihrer Tasche mit ihren Händen tief
in die Taschen tief in die Geldbeutel
der Menschen und nehmen das hat ersparte
Weg das ist die Wahrheit wenn Sie hier
lachen lachen draußen überhaupt niemand
wäre wenn sie nämlich kalt enteignet
werden und zwar von der FDP und den
Bundesfinanzminister Christian Lindner
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das ist
quasi ein Kleben in den Geldbeutel der
Menschen im übertragenen Sinn wenn sie
das verstehen vielleicht in dem Werding
Herr Kollege eine Zwischenfrage zulassen
Kollege Bremen ich bin muss ich bekennen
großer Bewunderer der bayerischen
Tradition auch im Bierzelt politische
Reden zu halten und habe auch großen
Anteil daran dass es ihnen regelmäßig
gelingt ausgerechnet in der trockenen
Steuerpolitik diese gute bayerische
Tradition sogar in den plenartzahl des
Deutschen Bundestages zu tragen
herzlichen Glückwunsch dafür früher war
es so dass die Union wenn das
Bundesverfassungsgericht bestimmte Dinge
verlangt hat zumindest noch ein bisschen
zugehört hat spielt bei ihnen gar keine
Rolle mehr beim Thema Erbschaftssteuer
jetzt aber ich will sie etwas anderes
Fragen das Steuergesetz wird im
Bundesrat behandelt werden und die
b-länder Seite die unionsgeführten
Landesregierungen haben drei Themen aus
dem Jahressteuergesetz aus 142 Seiten
angemeldet für den Vermittlungsausschuss
und Wunder das von ihnen gerade
angesprochene Thema mit großem Getöse
nämlich das Thema der Bewertung für die
Zecke der Erbschaftssteuer wurde von der
Union Seite für den
Vermittlungsausschuss nicht angemeldet
es wird also in der Bundesrat akzeptiert
werden und ich würde von ihnen jetzt
einfach gerne wissen wie es sein kann
dass sie dieses Thema hier riesengroß
skandalisieren und dort wo die Wahrheit
auf dem Platz liegt wo die Union
mitreden kann es noch nicht einmal für
eine weitere Beratung angemeldet wird
Herr Kollege haben sie dafür eine
Erklärung
herzlichen Dank dass Sie mir nochmal die
Gelegenheit geben hier ein bisschen
auszuführen also verfassungsrechtlich
geboten kann man diskutieren aber es ist
glaube ich gestern auch ich überhaupt
keine Frage habe ich gestern auch gesagt
es geht ja darum den gemeinen Werte
Immobilie darzustellen also da brauchen
sie mir keine Nachhilfe geben aber es
ist nicht aber es ist auch nicht
verboten die Freibeträge anzuheben und
sie haben das nämlich angekündigt auch
der Bundesfinanzminister hat es
angekündigt die Freibeträge anzuheben
und Geld passiert ist gar nichts und
wenn Sie Fragen im Bundesrat dann
empfehle ich Ihnen den Antrag des
Freistaats Bayern mit nämlich genau
dieser Sache Erhöhung der Freibeträge
und wenn Sie es ernst meinen würden als
FDP dann würden sie diesen Antrag des
Freistaats Bayern im Bundesrat auch
zustimmen und dann hätten wir auch das
Thema erledigt Erhöhung der Werte
Erhöhung der Freibeträge das wäre mit
uns in Ordnung wir haben zusätzlich noch
die Frage der Regionalität und der
Regionalisierung der Erbschaftssteuer
mit eingebracht
also ich denke wenn sie das ernst meinen
dann können wir das Miteinander umsetzen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
also wir können in diesem
Jahressteuergesetz aufgrund der drei
Faktoren die ich genannt habe also keine
Verfassungsmäßigkeit viel zu viel
Bürokratie und auch die Frage mit der
Erbschaft und Schenkungssteuer nicht
zustimmen auch wenn ich nicht für
Schweigen will dass einige Punkte
umgesetzt worden sind die für sich
gesehen in Ordnung sind Homeoffice
pauschale eine Idee übrigens der CSU
danke dass Sie das bestätigen ja da
brauchen Sie nicht Sie haben das letzte
Mal dagegen fast sogar geredet wie als
cdu/csu haben das ins Rennen gebracht
Verlängerung der Sonderabschreibung für
den mietwohnungs Neubau auch eine
cdu/csued die haben Sie das letzte Mal
auch kritisiert wurde die reichen nur
reicher machen jetzt setzen Sie es um
eine später Erkenntnis aber auch in
Ordnung aber was natürlich nicht dabei
ist was sie immer angekündigt haben zu
tun die Doppelbesteuerung die künftige
über den Renten zu beseitigen
Modernisierung der
Unternehmensbesteuerung und das
Vorziehen der kalten Progression auf
2022 deswegen können wir diesen Gesetz
nicht zustimmen wir lehnen dieses Gesetz
ab sie machen als Ampel die Menschen Tag
für Tag
ärmer in unserem Land und dagegen wären
wir uns mit aller entschiedenheiten
herzlichen Dank
Sebastian Brehm war das aus der
Unionsfraktion es geht hier nach wie vor
um das Jahressteuergesetz 2022 und da
ist durchaus Konfliktstoff drin und dazu
jetzt Stefan Schmidt aus der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Gründen Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen massiv
gestiegene Energiepreise hohe Inflation
einen unstillbarer Durst nach Öl und Gas
Putins Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
wirft lange Schatten mit dem
Jahressteuergesetz nehmen wir die Krisen
ganz gezielt in den Fokus wir entlasten
nicht nur die breite Bevölkerung die
Unternehmen die Kommunen wir geben auch
erneuerbaren Energien noch mal einen
kräftigen Schub ich behaupte wir haben
das Jahressteuergesetz zu einem echten
entlastungs-
besonders besonders freut mich
besonders freue ich mich über unsere
Beschlüsse zur Photovoltaik es wurde am
Ende der Stelle schon angesprochen
Menschen mit Photovoltaik-Anlagen auf
dem Dach die leisten einen
unverzichtbaren Beitrag zur
Energiesicherheit und Energiewende
deswegen ist es längst an der Zeit dass
wir sie von steuerlichen und
bürokratischen Hürden entlasten und
befreien wer eine Anlage auf dem Dach
hat muss keine Einkommensteuer keine
Gewerbesteuer keine Umsatzsteuer
bezahlen und wir Grüne haben erreicht
dass die Erträge sogar rückwirkend für
dieses Jahr von der Steuer befreit
werden
es profitieren also alle die die sich in
der Vergangenheit für eine Photovoltaik
entschieden
Photovoltaikanlage entschieden haben und
alle die diesen Vorbild nun folgen und
so werden eigene Anlagen auf dem Dach
noch attraktiver das ist ein wichtiger
Schritt um uns von der fossilen
Abhängigkeit zu befreien
mit dem Jahressteuergesetz unterstützen
wir auch viele Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer beim mobilen Arbeiten und
zwar auch diejenigen die kein separates
Arbeitszimmer zu Hause haben wir
entfristen die homeoffice-pauschale wir
machen es steuerlich attraktiv auf das
tägliche pendeln ins Büro zu verzichten
damit passen wir die Steuerrecht an die
moderne Arbeitswelt an und entlasten
auch hier die Menschen
und auch für Kommunen und den
öffentlichen Sektor haben wir etwas
rausgeholt unsere Städte und Gemeinden
auch die Forschungslandschaft sie leiden
extrem unter der aktuellen Krise deshalb
haben wir entschieden dass wir die
Übergangsregelungen im Paragraph 2b der
Umsatzsteuer des Umsatzsteuergesetzes zu
verlängern heißt im Klartext wir
befreien hier an dieser Stelle
Dienstleistungen der öffentlichen Hand
für zwei weitere Jahre bis Ende 2024 von
der Umsatzsteuer damit verschaffen wir
uns Zeit um rechtliche Unklarheiten zu
beseitigen und geben den Machern vor Ort
die steuerliche und bürokratische
Atempause die Sie jetzt brauchen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben
uns wir haben aus einem guten
Gesetzentwurf ein echtes
Entlastungspaket für gemacht wir
entlasten die breite Masse die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger die Unternehmen
die Kommunen wir schieben die
Energiewende an mit dem Beratungen zum
Jahressteuergesetz haben wir als
fortschrittskoalition wieder mal gezeigt
wir haben den Mut um wichtige Weichen zu
stellen und das Land erfolgreich aus der
Krise zu führen dafür herzlichen Dank
herzlichen Dank für die guten Beratungen
Dank an die Kolleginnen die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter und des
Bundesministerium für Finanzen
das Wort für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zunächst einmal
möchte ich mich dem Dank nochmal
anschließen dass man wirklich
aufreibende Verhandlungsrunden wir haben
18 Stück an der Zahl miteinander auch
verbringen dürfen wir haben glaube ich
eine Menge von wichtigen Themen
diskutiert und das Ergebnis kann sich
heute sehen lassen also vielen Dank noch
mal an die beiden ampelfraktionen an
meine
der Kollege Daldrup hat schon
angekündigt ich darf heute auch noch mal
was zur PV-Anlage sagen habe das auch in
meiner letzten Rede schon getan wäre ich
jetzt der Kollege Lindner würde ich
sagen wir entfesseln die
freiheitsenergien ich begnüg mich aber
damit dass wir PV-Anlagen einfach mal
attraktiver machen drei Punkte dabei wir
machen der Ertragsteuer frei bis Anlagen
bei 30 kW das ist glaube ich ganz
wichtig weil wir bisher immer Anlagen so
zwischen 7 und 15 kW haben der Grenzwert
war bei 10 das ist also ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt dort für Entlastung auch
zu sorgen ein zweiter Punkt ist der
notsteuersatz in der Umsatzsteuer der
glaube ich ganz ganz viele Menschen von
der Bürokratie befreit bisher haben sie
die Entscheidung entweder ich denjenigen
die kleine unternehmerregelung bekommen
aber meine Umsatzsteuer nicht zurück bei
der Solarenergie das ist besonders
Nachteil bei der Anschaffung weil seine
Anlage kostet gut und gerne mal 30.000 €
und dann 6000 € einfach zu verzichten
das ist besonders schade oder
andererseitig macht die Umsatzsteuer
bekommen Sie in der Anschaffung zurück
aber muss dann irgendwie alle zwei
Monate die Umsatzsteuer auch anmelden
das ist besonders für Bürokratie hier
sorgen wir für Anreize die kleine
teilnehmerregelung zu wechseln ohne
finanzielle Nachteile das auch glaube
ich noch mal ein ganz wichtiger Punkt
und der dritte Punkt ist dass wir den
Lohnsteuerhilfevereinen auch erlauben da
in dem Thema zu beraten dass es glaube
ich auch noch mal eine Abrundung der
ganzen Angelegenheit so wird es deutlich
attraktiver und einfacher für Menschen
sich eine PV-Anlage aufs Dach zu setzen
dennoch möchte ich jetzt auch noch mal
was zu Union sagen weil mich das in der
Debatte doch sehr geärgert hat Herr
Brehm hat davon gesprochen dass wir in
unserem Gesetz unstimmig sind ich hatte
er den Eindruck dass sie in ihrer
Argumentation unstimmig sind Frau
Tillmann hat als erstes gesprochen und
hat die ganze Zeit davon gesprochen wie
entlasten und gefährden die
Schuldenbremse die Hälfte der Redezeit
war irgendwie eine Gefahr für die
Schuldenbremse sie haben ein paar
Minuten später davon gesprochen dass wir
die Steuern so exorbitant erhöhen dass
wir viel mehr Einnahmen haben dass das
der Staat an die Taschen greift sie
müssen sich schon noch mal entscheiden
welche Strategie Sie hier in ihrer
redewende anwenden weil das wäre doch
deutlich plausibler wenn das auch einen
Sinn ergeben würde und ein letzter Punkt
noch dazu wir haben die Diskussion ja
gestern schon geführt und anscheinend
reicht ihm das ja immer noch nicht die
immobilienbewertungsordnung wurde von
ihrem eigenen CSU-Minister Seehofer in
geleitet das ist noch mal ganz wichtig
zu betonen und es ist keine
Steuererhöhung der Erbschaftssteuer das
wäre schön ist aber mit der FDP nicht zu
machen darüber können wir noch mal
diskutieren
wir können gerne über die Freibeträge
reden aber nur dann wenn wir die
betrieblichen Vermögen endlich anpacken
und es nicht mehr weiter zusehen dass
hier Milliarden von Erben jedes Jahr in
dem Staat Vorbeigehen das ist die
wirkliche Gerechtigkeitslücke und dafür
werden wir uns weiterhin einsetzen bitte
um ihre Zustimmung vielen Dank
und ich schließe die Aussprache und wir
kommen zur Abstimmung über den von der
Bundesregierung eingebrachten Entwurf
eines Jahressteuergesetzes 2022 der
Finanzausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache 47 29
den Gesetzentwurf der Bundesregierung
auf Drucksache 38 79 und 42 29 in der
ausschussfassung anzunehmen die Fraktion
der AFD hat beantragt über den
Gesetzentwurf in der ausschussfassung
getrennt abzustimmen und zwar zum einen
über die Artikel 29 und 40 das
Gesetzentwurfs Änderungen des
finanzverwaltungsgesetzes sowie des
Gesetzes zur Einführung eines
energiekrisenbeitrags nach der
Verordnung der EU 2022 18 54 und zum
anderen über den Gesetzentwurf im
übrigen ich rufe also zunächst auf die
übrigen Teile des Gesetzentwurfes in der
ausschussfassung ich bitte diejenigen
die die übrigen Teile des Gesetzentwurfs
in der ausschussfassung
zu ihrem Jahr versehen wollen um das
Handzeichen
wer stimmt dagegen
mir enthält sich
der Gesetzentwurf die übrigen Teile des
Gesetzentwurfes sind angenommen
zugestimmt hat die haben die
koalitionsfraktion dagegen gestimmt hat
die Unionsfraktion enthalten haben sich
linke und AFD ich rufe bitte
doch nicht
okay die AFD korrigiert ihr
Abstimmungsverhalten und hat zugestimmt
ich rufe nun auf die Artikel 29 und 40
in der ausschussfassung die Fraktion der
AFD hat hier namentliche Abstimmung
verlangt
sie haben dafür jetzt 20 Minuten Zeit
die Abstimmung erfolgt in der westlobby
unmittelbar nach Eröffnung der
namentlichen Abstimmung werden wir noch
weitere Abstimmungen durchführen
deswegen bitte ich die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen nicht alle den Saal zu
verlassen sondern im Gegenteil im Saal
noch hier zu bleiben die
schriftführerinnen und Schriftführer
haben die vorgesehenen Plätze
eingenommen dafür bedanke ich mich sehr
also sind die Urnen besetzt und ich
eröffne die namentliche Abstimmung über
den Gesetzentwurf der Bundesregierung
die Abstimmung werden wir schließen um
13 Uhr
oder 8 je nachdem das werden wir dann
schauen das bevorstehende Ende wird
Ihnen dann hier noch einmal bekannt
gegeben
jetzt kommen wir zur Beschlussempfehlung
des Finanzausschusses zu dem Antrag der
Fraktion der AFD mit dem Titel
tarifmäßig bei Einkünften aus Land und
Forstwirtschaft die Tarif Ermäßigung
Entschuldigung bei Einkünften Ausland
und Forstwirtschaft Fortführen der
Ausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache 37/72
den Antrag der Fraktion der
afd-sache 25 35 abzulegen der stimmt für
diese Beschlussempfehlung
das sind die Koalitionsfraktionen die
linke und die Union der stimmt dagegen
das ist die afd-fraktion gibt es
Enthaltungen das ist nicht der Fall dann
ist die Beschlussempfehlung angenommen
und wir kommen zur Beschlussempfehlung
des Finanzausschusses zu dem Antrag der
Fraktion der AFD mit dem Titel fehlender
Vertrauens und Rechtsschutz bei der
Besteuerung von
Photovoltaikanlagen Blockheizkraftwerken
der Ausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache
36,23 den Antrag der Fraktion der AFD
auf Drucksache 26 17 abzulegen wer
stimmt für diese Beschlussempfehlung
das sind die Koalitionsfraktionen die
cdu/csu und die Linke wer stimmt dagegen
das ist die afd-fraktion gibt es
Enthaltungen das ist nicht der Fall dann
ist die Damen und Herren die
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin katrin
Göring-Eckardt das ist ein durchaus
herausforderndes Unterfangen jetzt hier
dieses
Jahressteuergesetz 2022 abzustimmen man
kann grundsätzlich sich der Beschreibung
meines Kollegen er hat schärfer der sie
durch den Vormittag geführt hat
anschließend das ist in gewisser Weise
ein bisschen ein gemischt warenladen
einmal im Jahr müssen bestimmte Punkte
in der Steuergesetzgebung verabschiedet
werden es macht aber Sinn wenn man nicht
alles einzeln versucht sondern dies in
einem Gesetz zusammenpackt da sind eben
Dinge drin wie zum Beispiel die
Homeoffice pauschale da sind aber auch
drin Steuervorteile für Solaranlagen das
hat natürlich auch
ähm dann gibt es neue
Sonderabschreibungen im Mietwohnungsbau
das hat natürlich auch zur Folge dass es
in Detailfragen dann doch
unterschiedliche differente Auffassungen
in den verschiedenen Fraktionen des
Hauses gibt dabei sind wir gerade bis
hin zu dem was gerade auch im
Hintergrund läuft deswegen sehen Sie
diese Bewegung hier im Saal das aufgrund
und auf Antrag der afd-fraktion wir eine
namentliche Abstimmung haben die im
Hintergrund weiter